[Music]
jeff
hey neil so no one told me this i
discovered this on my own
that if
for those of you who have ridden
airplanes i know some people have never
been in an airplane i highly recommend
it it's quite a marvel of engineering
and physics and
and aerodynamics or you can watch
youtube okay
okay
so if you could save up if you've never
been on airplane find a place to fly to
and just check it out it's it's quite a
marvel
and i i marvel at every day even though
we've been doing it for more than 100
years so i know it's when i pull down
the shades
and i can't see outside
and i look at this
drink
and the water level is completely
horizontal okay
all right that means we're just there
we're not you know accelerating or
banking or turning okay it's just there
and
it stays that way the entire trip
right
now i know the plane has got to make
some turns when it comes i know it's got
to do this at some point right yes
if it does that
i would expect the water level to tilt
within the glass
i'd expect me to lean
in one way or another at the way it
would happen in a car
if you make a left turn in a car your
body
leans to the right
okay because you actually want to keep
going in a straight line but the car is
curving in front of you so it feels like
you're getting pushed to the right but
really you're just going in this you
want to go in a straight line the car
won't let you you're getting pushed
against the door okay or you turn left
or right whichever or someone's sitting
next to you your shoulders will touch
all right
no longer does that happen on an
airplane
what i did was let me try this with the
shade up
i do it with the shade up
i look out this window i see sky i look
out across the plane i see the ground
this sucker is banking
and yet the water on my table is
completely flat
okay
so
there's only one thing that can be
happening here because i don't think
humans have this ability
the computer is flying the airplane
and you program into the computer
such that the radius of the turn
and the speed at which you're going
requires that the plane be at a certain
banking angle
so that all the centrifugal forces
combine with gravity
so that
you don't even know you're banking this
term
in other words
the urge to fall into the middle of the
circle gets completely balanced with the
centrifugal force to send you out of the
circle so that the gravity vector still
goes directly to the bottom of the glass
and to your rump into the chair and you
don't even know
the plane is turning
those three numbers
if you if you choose them correctly you
can have them conspire so that you would
never know the plane was ever turning at
any time well clearly you have never
been on spirit airlines
the pilot's in there
they don't even you they don't even use
the joists they use a actual steering
wheel
[Laughter]
i'm sure it's a fine airline where they
have fully trained pilots
but the precision necessary to do that
to do that reliably to do that without
the judgment of the pilot
is
um
that that takes a computer and if you
look at old movies where they show
people on airplanes and the airplane is
turning you'll see people sort of
leaning to the one side or the other
that is no longer a thing in airplanes
and you know what you just reminded me
of when you're talking about going back
is old episodes of star trek
the first star trek where the entire
crew
would go to the left
and then they go to them they leaned
hold on
and they'd all be instructed to do this
right so
they take the camera and tip the camera
and they tip the camera and they would
all do that to make it look like they
were banking and they were in space so
so if you if you bank a turn properly
you never feel that that effect and by
the way we've talked about this with
nascar
all right what the banked turn
in a race track
there is a speed with which you can
drive your car
so that you never have to
touch the steering wheel and the car
will make a complete turn on that bank
and end up going back the other way
right
and that speed is one where you will not
feel like you're
leaning to the left or the right
because the road is turning for you the
road is turning the car for you
correct
and at the right speed you'll feel the
gravity vector doing whatever was doing
before you entered that turn it's the
same physics principle
at work there
so i just thought i'd put that out there
just a little uh discovery i made i
haven't checked with anybody
who did it and when it started but i
still i began noticing it and you should
notice it too
check it out it could be sky here and
brown down there and
you don't even notice it unless you look
out the damn window
yeah yeah the same well you know i had i
fly spirits so i've noticed it all the
time
it's tough
one last thing
if you are
in space
uh-huh
there is no
banking of turns
yes okay well i'll tell you why because
because so so on a track the thing
that's turning the car for you is the
road itself okay okay that's a force
there that's turning the car
if you are in an airplane you are
banking on a cushion of air
as you complete your turn
if you're in space there is no force
doing that
so if you're in space you just have to
fire rockets
right and and so so
so they don't tip and turn uh it looks
cool when the tie fighters did that in
star wars and and and the millennium
falcon you know it looks cool but that's
not how it would happen you just have
the rockets change the direction um that
that it turns in so all of those
maneuvers that you see the millennium
falcon make went into yeah the maneuvers
for they're atmospheric maneuvers
they're not yeah
none of that means anything right right
it's right yeah wow
plus didn't they at the end of the star
wars episode four when they had the the
you know
uh
they were celebrated for destroying the
the death star the death star they
didn't they just fly in from an open
bay
exposed to the vacuum of space
and then they just get out and walk
around
yes
i see
i think there's a force shield that
holds the atmosphere inside the ship
though well you just made that up right
now no no i'm serious
okay okay
that's i think that's how it works okay
magic force field okay
like yeah i mean but seriously there's
nothing in star wars that that's
scientific let's be honest
i mean seriously there's you know the
least believable thing to me was here's
the here the fighter is coming in and
there's the guy
with with the with the traffic codes
directing
you don't have a better way to do this
in the 25th century or whenever the hell
this thing takes place and the other
thing is too they all fly in and um
nobody fires retro rockets
oh they just slow down they just slow
down like in star trek though when you
fly into a shuttle bay
uh there is a kind of like a tractor
beam that grabs you and then you come in
and that's correct correct because star
trek thinks about science yeah but star
wars they're just like you know coming
in
they're coming in hot
all right so this is this is airplane
banking 101 jack
well that's cool actually all right this
has been uh an explainer jamboree stuff
you thought you knew in three segments
and so i hope you like these chuck cause
i you know i bend your ear on them i
love them uh they're great i mean and i
actually do
learn stuff and i gotta tell you man
that i mean they're they're it's really
it's great information to have
at a cocktail party okay
because you'd otherwise just be
completely boring
i gotta pull out of nihilism here just
exactly it's like you should go talk to
that guy i thought he was a stupid
comedian but god he's brilliant guys
brilliant
i thought he was a stupid comedian
so chuck we got to call this one quits i
hope you enjoyed this one always always
very good very good neil degrasse tyson
here as always
[Music]